but let's talk about uh
let's talk about you know i guess the
left and hypocrisy because we got this
uh this story here uh-oh it's from the
other day actually but it's been picking
up okay boomer tick-tock influencer
called hypocrite after showing off two
million dollar flat everybody knows uh
nico lowell she is an influencer and if
you're not if you don't know who she is
just take a look at uh george over here
he's got a a picture that he drew
what kind of freak you would draw that
yeah especially at top left something's
wrong with that artist yeah who hurt him
biden emerging from the wall like some
kind of gigantic junji ito demon
so what's happening in this in this
piece of art george
well she uh she regrets being
a part of the party that ended up
devouring her i mean she was obviously
supporting one guy
and then oh no it's the other guy
and you fed him turns out you fed him
the whole time there are like other
faces in his body
oh yes you see there's the sequel
my book oh no it's uncle joe which is
not oh no it's not based on anyone real
you see
where the story is that uh
you know there's okay okay so anyway
this is uh she's she's a very popular
influencer she she did this dance she
probably saw it where she's saying okay
boomer gets 50 million views now she's
rich the thing is everybody's dragging
her because she's got a bernie shirt on
she's wearing a tax the rich shirt and
then she makes a video where she's like
my two million dollar apartment the
first thing i'll just say is
when did you expect that why would you
believe that any of these people
actually knew or understood economics or
politics
right
like all of these young dsa types my
assumption immediately is that
they're children
you know that's why they have that
saying it's like um if you're not uh
conservative when you're older you have
no head if you're not liberal when
you're young you have no heart or
whatever
well i think it's obvious everybody's
liberal until they look at their first
paycheck and then they realize where the
taxes are going i'll tell you i wasn't
liberal before then dude i worked for uh
when i when i worked for american
airlines i remember i was like i was
always waiting for the young like
younger guys who got hired to look at
their paycheck and then just be like
i remember the first time i got a
paycheck i had jobs before this i worked
at some fast food restaurants i worked
at portillo's people you guys you guys
know portillo's portillos is the best
yes it's totally lit and i worked there
and then i got a job at the airline and
i worked you know
80 hours in two weeks and i was like i
had a general idea of taxes and what i
was going to get and i needed
desperately the money and i look at my
check and i'm like
nah this ain't right and i was like
there's something wrong with my check
and they're like no look there it is all
the breakdowns there and i was like why
am i being taxed so much yep like that
blew my mind i'm like bro i'm poor i
can't afford that but it's insane they
talk about raising the minimum minimum
wage while they're taxing people who
make minimum wage it's like how about
you just take less of their money oh
that's a great idea yeah i mean they get
it back at the end of the year for the
most part if they're poor but anyway
what ends up happening is you get you
get a lot of people who go to college
they never had a job yeah so while
they're in college they hear bernie
socialism communism and all the other
stuff they've never had a job
then when they get out what happens some
of them become famous
start making
hundreds of thousands of dollars
millions of dollars and now they're just
like
okay boomer you know yeah buy two
million dollar flat or whatever i don't
know if she actually bought it but they
just they never actually understood any
of the politics they were espousing
because i tell you this any one of these
people if they had to provide for a
family they'd be like abolish taxes yes
taxation is that 100 the moment they
look they're like i just worked all year
and what do i have to show for it well
40 of your income i think the total
taxes with sales tax and everything it's
like 48 or something like that of your
income goes to the government
or higher with sales tax and also
depends on how you look at it so
if you're self-employed or you run your
own business you have to pay more into
social security you pay in what your
employer would normally pay and what
people don't realize is like
their employer when they do pay into
that they're taking that out of that
person's check so you're paying more
into taxes than you actually think you
are so so this is uh this okay boomer
thing right at first
i was actually gonna do a segment where
i was like guys i really don't care that
she's rich you can be you can be a lefty
and still believe in like class and
wealth if you're like dem yeah maybe
right right right and so i'm like
there's there's nuance here maybe she's
gonna learn but then i saw this video
where she's like she made a video called
how much money do i make and she said i
think when people are talking about the
wealthy they're talking like about
billionaires and i'm like oh here we go
that's hilarious i'm not so i here's the
thing i made this joke years ago i did a
cartoon about the um
99.99 complaining about the .01 percent
oh oh one percent or one percent um and
the whole bit was that
in the united states where the vast
majority of people have a standard of
life significantly higher than basically
everyone else in the world so if you
make more than thirty thousand dollars a
year you're in the top one percent of
the world economy and people in the u.s
are constantly complaining i shouldn't
say all people in the us but many are
constantly complaining about income
inequality
and it's literally like to some extent
millionaires complaining about
billionaires not always i understand
when you get into things like health
care there are actually a lot of
legitimate problems that need to be
solved there but
i think it's funny that now we literally
do have millionaires complaining about
billionaires like it's a joke i made
years ago and it's an actual thing which
is happening i would you know you should
you should make a video with bernie
being like
i am a humble millionaire upset with the
billionaires look how much i have to
work but if you write a best-selling
book you can be a millionaire but it's
gotta be like he's leading a rally of
millionaires
it's a bunch of millionaires with
pitchforks angry at the baby like i did
i i made a cartoon like that years ago
and it was it was these rich guys
complaining about how other people are
more rich than that it is unfair and now
that i have to write an entire book to
buy my fourth house there might be
something to it because the founding
fathers of the united states were
basically millionaires of their time up
against the billionaire of their time
the king who was unfairly
you know fiscally robbing them taxing
them and so these big companies with
these bailouts and are basically that
that's a modern-day monarchy and maybe
maybe we need a class of millionaires to
rise up and fix things it's there there
is a massive disparity between the
wealthiest and the poorest in the world
that's like we've never seen before so
what happens is in the us you end up
with these like what do we call mystery
silver spoon socialists
where there's someone super chat
yeah so she's a silver socialist where
they're like supporting bernie sanders
and democratic socialism while they're
millionaires complaining about
billionaires and i'm like dude i think
it's all bad i get it people are allowed
to be rich i got no problem with people
being rich i'm saying
my problem is with the ultra wealthy
manipulating elections and using undue
influence and everything it's a
challenge i know how you solve it
because it's not just about having money
like the fact that we that i have the
show that we're on the show is more
valuable than money people pay so that
they can get a message out across
through the show or something so i don't
know how you actually deal with problems
like that but i can tell you this
someone who's got 50 million dollars has
massive power and someone with a billion
dollars has a lot more but they can
still have massive influence over over
elections
yeah you don't need money to be super
popular and influential you just need a
little bit just put hold it up no are
you sure of this acceptable don't do it
why not don't do it don't okay i gotta
do
well so this is the funny thing about
nikola i'll take your money that's right
i'll do it i'll draw butts all the time
the the funny thing about nicole though
is that people are commenting like
people like peop people are dragging her
being like you're a hypocrite and all
that stuff but her fans are like i
literally only follow her for her body i
don't care what she believes
whatever man she's getting rich with
that fine whatever it's her hustle
whatever everybody's got their own
hustle
i yeah also i don't know what we were
expecting from like the tick tocker here
at the same time maybe maybe that's a
little condescending i mean what i'm
like i'm a youtuber so maybe i shouldn't
be dumping on tick tockers but i like to
think we're like a little bit above that
i like to think i'm not hope so i think
dragon bernie is perfectly perfectly
appropriate absolutely i do he stopped
saying millionaire when he became a
millionaire no joke like there was an
article it's like you can track the
moment he removed a millionaire from his
speeches and it's around the same time
he became a millionaire
that's the stupidest thing ever welcome
to the club of wanting money like we
were talking about this before we went
on air i don't see why every young
people isn't saying i want to be a
millionaire i want to do whatever is
morally okay with me whatever i'm going
to do what's got to be done to earn a
living and maybe earn more than a living
so i can you know take care of my family
whatever buy a nice car if you want to
buy a nice car there's no guilt fact i
don't understand why people have this
guilt of like
it's okay to make money
and yes have the money and then you know
you can spread it to other places invest
give it to other people so they can do
things with that money don't just sit on
you know people have this idea of all
right so there's the idea of if uh
certain people
who don't have a lot of money win the
lottery it actually is worse for them in
the long run because they don't know how
to spend the money or save it or
reinvest it but like if you
i feel like if you have this uh if you
work for your money maybe you have a
little bit more of uh
you understand the value of that dollar
or something it's like i have a couple
of dollars in my pocket i'm not going to
just let it sit there i want to make it
do something i want to buy bitcoin
it doesn't matter you got it the whole
point is you've got to try this idea of
when you have a couple of bucks you
don't just sit on it you don't just
waste it you want to try to do something
with it give it to other people hire
other people so that you can make more
money and they can make more money that
that's the point of that's one of the
good things about earning money so i can
unders i can understand how
you might look at someone who has a lot
and just assume they're just going to
waste it all all the time but
everybody thinks they should have your
everybody thinks they should be rich
well that's kind of i mean you sound a
little keynesian for me on the the point
about savings but i hear you i think
what it goes back to is what we
discussed earlier with people thinking
the only reason anyone has money is
because they've done something evil to
get it and if you're at the top of that
hierarchy it must be because you
participated in a rigged game yeah of
course until they get some yeah until
they get some and then they're like well
actually and then you can become a
billionaire a millionaire ethically but
billionaires and then as soon as jeff
bezos becomes a trillionaire it's just
gonna be him that everyone's mad at but
billionaires are gonna be like no being
a billionaire is the trillionaires who
are really doing it too we we need a
bernie in 10 years and he's like really
old and he's a billionaire now because
he wrote like he wrote a thousand new
best-selling books and made a billion
dollars and he's like
the
multi-billionaires in this country uh of
the problem not not the billionaires and
then it's like jeff he's like he's like
he's looking at his phone and he's
sweating and it says like jeff business
net worth and it's at 999 billion and
then it rolls over to one trillion he
goes the trillionaires in this country
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you